this is a production of Cornell
University all right thanks everyone for
taking the time to be here today I'm
excited to share my dissertation work um
titled how do we know a soil is healthy
and how does it relate to soil carbon
sequestration just for context I want to
share um what my whole dissertation
involves five chapters today I'm not
going to be presenting on chapter one
cropping system and soil texture shape
soil Health outcomes and chapter three
on the development of pedotransfer
functions for available water capacity
because I presented on those topics
three years ago in in Department seminar
but today we'll be focusing on chapter
two on production environment soil
Health benchmarks considering soil type
cropping system and Regional context on
chapter four on the development of pedot
transfer functions for soil protein and
on chapter five on the effects of
tillage cropping system soil type on
soil organic carbon stocks at three of
New York's oldest a
experiments so to set the stage for
today I want to discuss the triple
threat to Agriculture and Global Food
security seen from space humans have
been a soil degrading species in the
last 30 years 22% of agricultural land
has undergone measurable soil
degradation and here we can see wind
erosion taking soil particles away but
we don't don't see the invisible flux of
carbon dioxide leaving the soil so if we
don't
replace um the organic matter that's
lost each year we'll have soil
degradation loss of soil functioning at
the same time we have agricultural
nutrient pollution that exacerbates
global warming in the terms of nitrous
oxide and and and threatens aquatic
water bodies globally meanwhile we have
extreme precipitation events droughts
heat waves that are predicted to
increase in magnit magnitude and
frequency and this this farmer right
here is from 2016 where there was a
hundred-year drought in Western New York
and these events are predicted to
increase in
frequency and and the this Triple Threat
really um sets the stage for the
importance of sustainable soil
management strategies that increase
carbon inputs and reduce disturbance to
increase resiliency and potential
mitigate some of the impacts of climate
change so it's not all doom and gloom
New York is a leader in soil health and
climate change with some of the most
ambitious climate legislation in the
country New York signed the climate
leadership and Community protection act
in 2019 also known as the
clcpa which calls for 85% reduction in
Greenhouse gash emissions by 2050 so
incredibly ambitious
Target at the same time we also have
some very exciting soil health and
climate resiliency legislation that was
passed unanimously in December
20121 and calls for increase in
financial and technical assistance for
support practices that improve soil
Health increase climate resiliency and
reduce greenhouse gas emissions a
commitment to scientific research on
soil health and carbon sequestration and
the establishment of voluntary soil
Health targets which is a perfect segue
into my chapter
two which is about developing the
foundation for this
science so chapter 2 um is about
production environment soil Health
benchmarks that consider soil type
cropping system and Regional context and
this is really the scientific Foundation
that we're proposing could be the
foundation for these voluntary soil
standards just some terminology
introduction production environment
might be a New Concept but that word um
really helps to encapsulate the soil
type cropping system and Regional
differences in a single peer group so we
could an example could be LOM textured
soils annual grain cropping systems in
Upstate New York so just for some
context our lab our lab group uses the
cornal soil Health laboratory
comprehensive assessment of soil Health
it's the first commercial soil Health
laboratory in in the world and the cash
test captur all important soil processes
physical biological and chemical and
there's four physical indicators four
biological and four chemical with their
with their measurements and
then the cache framework interprets
those measured values based on texture
to give ratings that help interpret
those measure values helps to identify
soil constraints provides guidance for
management and the lab has processed a
huge number of soil samples over the
last 10 years and B been a real model um
for this comprehensive soil testing
approach and been a major tool by
different research and Outreach
initiatives across the country so we can
think of three major factors of soil
health and you might have seen this
conceptualization from Valentina Rubio
we could think of the inherent factors
things like parent material or minology
climate biology slope and time and these
factors all come together to shape
inherent soil properties like texture
drainage those are properties that we
are stuck with and have no control over
then there's cropping system these are
the cropping systems across the
landscape in New York we have an
incredible diversity of cropping systems
annual grain Orchard vegetable pasture
and
this really impacts soil Health through
the different um carbon and nitrogen
cycling regimes that these different
systems have and because some of this is
structural there's limited control Ro um
in in changing the cropping system
because if you're growing annual grain
you're not likely to to switch to a
pasture system for example and this is
another good opportunity to introduce
this production environment concept this
production environment really is
creating a peer group of of inherent
properties and cropping system that we
can use to create benchmarks and
interpret soil Health in the context of
natural soil forming factors and the
cropping system context and finally
within each of those cropping systems
the farmer has ultimate control to
choose their crop rotation cover
cropping tillage choices organic
Amendment choices fertility choices so
with each of those cropping systems
there's that third level of the
management specificity within each
cropping
system so first I'm going to talk about
these factors of soil health these
inherent soil types and and also the
influence of climate on so on soil
Health measurements and we really need
to get a handle on these inherent
effects so that we can assess the
effects of
management so here's biological
indicators by soil texture so we have
four soil texture groups and four
biological indicators that are included
and we've known as soil scientists for a
long time that finer textured soils with
more fine silt and Clay tend to have
higher organic matter and stabilized
organic matter against decomposition
than corser tectri soils the same is
true for some of these other more novel
biological indicators that are more
sensitive to management and this is
really important for being able to
assess the effects of management and a
good example is let's say you're a Sandy
LOM soil or a CO texured soil having an
organic matter of 4.1 would be really
really good for you but would be a
pretty average value for if your soil
texture is silt loan so so really
important inherent context for
interpreting soil
Health next when we can think of the
regional impacts on soil Health U and we
split it out by region but I really want
you to think about climate one of the
regions that really pulled apart as we
were doing this New York soil Health
characterization work was kind of the
inherent differences um between Long
Island and the rest of New York state so
it appeared when we were comparing all
these
same the same cropping systems and the
same textures between the rest of New
York State and Long Island we were
seeing large differences in organic
matter between the two so here we have
these are all just
pastures um so the Course Long Island
had about one to 2% organic matter
differences across these whole groups
and this makes sense from a climate
perspective this makes sense when you
talk or resonates when you talk to
people like ol gavar who work on Long
Island and and in other parts of New
York who like know these so soil color
differences and and know this is true so
long island has a lot more coarser
texured soils it's kind of the Glacial
Marine and also has quite a bit warmer
climate maritime climate compared to the
continental climate so this is really
important context to think about we also
know that cropping system and the degree
of nutrient cycling disturbance um
carbon balance infl uence soil health
and all those different management
practices and you can think of um two
Extremes in terms of
um cropping systems and their influence
on carbon and nutrient cycling and
balances and degrees of disturbance with
this example so we have these natural or
pasture systems photosynthesizing year
round 90 to 100% of that biomass is
cycled in place doesn't leave doesn't
leave the site we have no disturbance to
to tillage and happy
earthworms and then we can contrast it
with a system that we're using really
intensely for agriculture as a annual
grain system or processing vegetable
system where we're harvesting maybe 50
to 70% of the carbon and nutrients in
our crop crop Harvest and Export um
we're having other losses from tillage
and
erosion and less cycling of organic
matter and less happy earthworms and in
conventional and traditional
agriculture we replace the nutrients
with synthetic fertilizer it's easier to
move around lighter weight but not that
carbon which leads to soil degradation
so this think about this in the context
of the next results I'm going to give
you for the past five years we've been
really fine-tuning and looking at the
effects of the different cropping
systems in New York on soil health so
now we're looking at six cropping
systems we have annual grain systems um
corn soybeans sometimes corn soybean
wheat rotations maybe dry beans um
growing the grain we have a lot of dairy
dair's really big in New York state um
corn silage alphalpha rotations but
there's a trend towards rotations that
have more corn silage in them we have a
lot of pastures pastured Dairy and beef
in New York state continuous living
Roots all year round Orchard systems um
perennial system so some het j8 within
the row and between the row so I leave
that complexity to Debbie we have this
mixed vegetable system diverse array of
vegetables grown in a smaller area these
tend to be kind of your organic
vegetable Farms market Gardens growing a
diverse array of products from market
and then in mostly in Western New York
we have some really larger processing
Vegetable Farms Farms growing tens to
hundreds Acres of cabbage snap beans um
pumpkin
sweet corn Etc so this distinguishment
is
important so here we're going to look at
soil organic matter and aggregate
stability in a second by cropping system
and we're controlling the inherent
context because we know that that those
really those things really affect soil
Health as well so we want to be able to
compare apples to
apples Orchard in there too and we know
that this we were seeing consistently
across soil texture groups that the
pastures and mixed vegetable operations
maintain the highest soil organic matter
you can think of dairy as being kind of
intermediate has this very intense part
of the rotation with corn silage but
also has a lot of manure and perennial
forages then our systems that are most
intensely used annual grain and
processing vegetable have the lowest
soil Health outcomes we're using them
very hard for
agriculture for aggregate stability
really important physical soil Health
indicator about soil structure and soil
resiliency p fers had two to three times
as much aggregate stability as all these
other annual systems so has a really
important signature of disturbance or
lack thereof disturbance and really
resonates with all the work that's been
done that shows that continuous living
roots and their Associated micro ISO
fungi really help to build and maintain
Aggregates so we have these big this
this growing New York State database
with soil type region and cropping some
context so now we can we're working to
advance the interpretation of soil
values so that farmers can compare
themselves to their peers which is who
they really want to compare themselves
with so here's a real Dairy Farmer I
worked with I obscured his name so moo
dairy farm we have some soil Health
benchmarking graphics for the farmer and
this was really nice proof of concept
for him been really invested heavily in
in no till and cover crops for the last
15 years a really nice proof of concept
that his organic matter was in the top
20th percentile and one of the higher
aggregate stability values we saw in
that peer
group and we've also been working on
soil Health benchmarking infographics
for the consumer so these would be for
Farms that are more consumer consumer
facing small scale Market Market Gardens
Orchards Farmers that are interfacing
with the consumer so this this might be
a tool that could be placed on a website
and actually if you check out Norwich
Meadows website they just updated it and
have their first feature they were kind
of the pilot farm for this development
yes La last year or you might have this
printed out in a poster for Farmers
Market um and you could share this with
Buyers this is made to be simple just
with a soil Health score and then we
focused on carbon instead of organic
matter because we know that there's this
huge huge growing interest in the public
for for carbon farming and climate
change mitigation and all
that so setting benchmarks for soil
Health bench marks exist for water and
air so why not soil soil Health
benchmarks can help farmers calibrate
their management more specifically and
provide kind of realistic targets
compared to their peers and they can
also potentially be used in um to in
different policy
initiatives so but as we showed these
benchmarks need to be adapted to soil
type region and cropping system
context so this is what we're calling
this our scientific foundation for these
benchmarks that will be will be handed
over to the state to develop these
voluntary standards so we've calling
them production environment soil Health
benchmarks or pesh and an example again
because this production environment
concept is maybe not straightforward is
that a production environment might be
at annual grain LOM texured soils and
Upstate New York so we have annual grain
and pasture here this is based on kind
of a prob probabilistic or fuzzy logic
approach and this is similar to how you
how blood pressure is interpreted by
weight or size or something like that so
we've decided that 90th percentile is a
good way to start the conversation it's
a realistic goal within the peer group
10% of the farmers Fields have been able
to achieve those goals and establishes
clear Pathways and realistic targets so
if you start with a organic matter value
of 2.5 you know that it's possible to
achieve this 3.
seven we also thought it was really
important to develop a universal
Benchmark for all of the different
cropping systems um and pastures are
that are that kind of best case scenario
for soil health so for a given soil type
of region kind of represents that upper
upper limit um in the past we've always
with our soil sampling we've always
recommended contrast sampling um so now
we have that kind of pasture data to
assess the effects of our man agement
other systems and in our lab we focus a
lot on extension materials um and these
are some of the extension materials that
we've developed to share this with the
public and here's a new hot off the
press soil Health benchmarks for New
York's Farm policy brief that just came
out all right so now I'm going to
transition to chapter
four um on pedot transfer functions for
soil protein based on random Forest
modeling for routine soil health
analysis basically the idea of EX
replacing a measurement with a
prediction for more costeffective soil
Health
assessment terms of terminology a pedot
transfer function is basically a model
that helps us predict something that's
costly to measure from something that's
easier to
measure so background soil protein is an
important biological soil Health
indicator provides an assessment of the
size of the organic nitrogen pool and
provides indirect measure of a soil's
ability ability to supply
nitrogen um has been shown to be very
sensitive to management so a good soil
Health indicator and also positive
correlations with non-legume prop yield
as agronomist figuring out drivers of
prop yield is is our Holy Grail so this
seems like a useful indicator for that
one of the Practical research questions
I worked with Bob a couple years ago to
develop this model of can we replace
this costly soil protein measurement
with prediction to prove the cost
effectiveness of soil Health assessment
still provide the information but
provide a a model estimated value so
with this kind of work we build models
we validate models we can use machine
learning models to actually gain
insights to what the variable is
um in an additional to just normal
linear regression and we wanted to
demonstrate whether the model could pick
up the same sensitivity to the
measurement so we have a very large um
National Database of soil Health
measurements one of the largest around
um and about 4,600 samples and the first
process was was determining the
variables that were most um most
predictive or most useful we didn't want
to include variables that weren't
parsimonious Etc so we removed a bunch
we have this great napam data set
looking at a number of long-term
experiments across the United States to
be as our independent validation data
set we looked at a bunch of variable
importance and partial dependence to
gain insights and we determine the
sensitivity of measured and modeled soil
protein on 57 long-term
experiments so this is kind of boring
but is is useful for um lab people who
are interested in this basically our
machine learning model we use one called
random Forest is able to reduce the
prediction error so significantly
compared to these other models and we've
determined that it's an
acceptable rmsse or mean square error
basically prediction accuracy for
commercial use I'm going to skip this um
and basically we wanted to assess um the
sensitivity of the measured and modeled
protein to management we have 57
replicated long-term experiments
basically the best of the best of
long-term experiments across the country
soil Pro was sensitive to single Way
Treatment effect at 36 out of 57 of
those compare that to soil organic
carbons maybe slight greater sensitivity
compared to soil organic carbon we found
that tillage and organic amendments were
the management levers that were most
likely to affect soil protein compared
to cover cropping system residue return
and cover crops found that um soil
protein was more sensitive to management
at coar textured sites compared to
medium and fine textured sites and then
that what was really cool at the end was
seeing that my machine learning model
was able to replicate those significant
findings at 92% of those sites so that's
another really good proof of concept
that our model is doing really well um
at at estimating soil
protein so finally let's go deeper soil
health is really about us usually not
because we're lazy but we usually we
focus on the top six inches for
practical purposes but we really need to
go deeper in understanding the effects
of management especially if that are
long-term s so what about the effects
below 15 CMS or 6 in and this is the
focus of my chapter five on effects of
tillage cropping system and soil texture
on carbon stocks in three long-term
experiments so for context soils are the
largest terrestrial carbon sync and have
a role to play in climate change
mitigation notice how I said rooll I
think we there's a lot of hype in the
public about the the benefits of of
carbon farming and the promises of
regenerative agriculture um in in
popular culture so I think we need to be
real there's a lot of claims out there
that regenerative agriculture is going
to stop the rise of CO2 in the
atmosphere probably not and we also
we've had a hyperfocus on carbon and
methane but we can't forget about
nitrous oxides that are really lower
hanging fruit for addressing Greenhouse
gashes from agriculture so some bigger
context this was
optimistic um soil carbon sequestration
claim from some from some top leading
soil scientists in this
area with with large Investments
potentially we can do 36% of total us a
a emissions or to 3.7% of total us
emissions so some of the most optimistic
soil scientists um are are very
different from what what we see in the
pop popular culture sometimes and then I
also wanted to share some about the
benefits of no till and strip till
because the results I'm going to present
I don't want to leave you with the wrong
ideas at the end so no till and strip p
is incre important at reducing erosion
increasing infiltration by having
residue armor of the soil surface really
improves soil health and climate
resiliency at the
surface significant Improvement in
operation profitability the reason no
till and strip till are so widespread
across the
landscape partially because of the
environmental benefit it but also
because the the pro the economics of it
worked out as
well may increase yields and the context
really depends on how well no till or
strip till is
implemented so if you asked a soil
scientist 20 years ago um does no till
sequester carbon I think the mainstream
um view would be that it does but is it
true and how relevant is it for New York
state so here's our what what I'm
calling plow till this board plow would
be followed by secondary tillage and
here's uh a really Innovative form of no
till planting green into high residue
biomass so notil increases soil organic
carbon and soil Health at the surface
but research has really challenged
whether that holds for the whole soil
profile and it makes sense as soil
scientists that we would think that what
we're seeing at the surface probably
holds true if you go down in depth but
turned out that that wasn't true um so
researchers began noting that basically
a lot of these studies were done with
less than or equal to 30 cmers of
sampling depth and were insufficient and
then when you go a little bit deeper the
data tells you can tell you the opposite
story um or tells you that there's no
differences so these were some of these
first papers about 15 years ago um that
began questioning this and this has
become kind of a main more more
mainstream View you actually to soil
science but it's really challenging when
we're communicating to Farmers and then
our our our stories are changing from
decade to decade so for my research
questions I was asking how much organic
carbon has been lost for some of these
long-term experiments looking at some of
the three longest term tillage
experiments in New
York what is no till lead to Greater
soil organic carbon stocks compared to
plow till in New York state we need to
ask ask the question to our long-term
experiments what role does texture play
and are there interactions between
tillage and cropping system organic
carbon input level on soil organic
carbon
stocks so here's our long-term tillage
sites um these were basically started at
the early part of Harold's career in
1992 spent a lot of time 30 minutes
south of platsburg for my research um
and at the willsboro research Farm Great
Farm manager up there Mike Davis and we
have basically these two parallel
experiments really great site because we
can drive less than a mile and be on a
clay LOM site one of the clest soil
textures I work with and then also a
lomy fine sand site which is one of the
cor this texture kind of like a beach
and we have this contrast to plow till
no till corn silage you can see that
greater than 90 maybe 95% of that above
ground biomass is harvested which is a
big issue in corn silage systems and
these systems are also unique in that
there are no manure inputs
here we also have a third experiment at
the Musgrave research Farm looking at
plow till versus no till corn grain so
that maybe 50 to 60% of those 55% of
those above ground biomass is is going
back into the soil and we
also had the introduction of cover crops
at the last seven years of the
experiment this wonderful guy named Matt
Ryan came to Cornell and asked Harold if
you could add some interceded cover
crups to
experiment so for methods pretty
straight forward I collected five 0 to
45 centimeter cores for plot two
adjacent cores at on saw ground to
understand the effects of management on
soil Health relative to under adjacent
sod so 270 cores altoe about 90 cores
each year split cores into 0 and to 7 .5
CM 7.5 to 15 15 to 30 30 to
45 measured bulk density submitted
samples for total carbon nitrogen soil
inorganic carbon organic carbon is total
carbon minus inorganic carbon here are
some really cool pictures you can really
see the stratification of carbon in the
no tilil system versus the deeper mixing
in plow
tilil so how much soil organic carbon
has been lost since the initial
conversion of hag ground to this
continuous corn silage system and the
willsboro plots give us this unique
opportunity because those before the
corn silage experiments they were in
long-term sod for for decades before
that so we can really assess um what
what that declin been due to this
intensive corn silage system
significance we kind of mentioned that
last week in Alison's talk and the
questions but corn Dairy cropping
rotations are changing nationally in um
the Midwest and here as well where we're
seeing alala acreage go down in New York
that's about 40% or 3 4,500,000 acres in
the last 20 years and some of that
decline is being made up with more
intense um Dairy cropping rotations with
more corn silage basically mostly driven
by economic factors but has negative
implications for soil
Health basically we used the Assad
adjacent benchmarks and we also had some
historic iCal samples from 1995 from the
early days of GPS they were able to use
to estimate initial carbon stocks so
here's my estimate of initial carbon
stocks for the lomy sand and clay LOM at
84 and
108 and now the current s so stock from
all the work measuring it 52 and a half
and
76.6 interestingly both of these
experiments Lomi sand and clay LOM lost
a similar magnitude of carbon
but when you compare that to the initial
stock the loss is about a little bit
higher of percentage of that initial
stock for the LOM
sand so the big question from this
chapter at least does no till lead to
consistent differences in carbon stocks
compared to plow till in New York and no
only one of three sites had
significantly higher stocks than our
notel lomy sand was almost
significant and then there was no
difference in actually
a higher numerical value for the plow
till and this is really
counterintuitive from being an
agronomist and being around all of the
excitement actually in the clay LOM site
you can really see the organic matter
differences at the surface it's about a
percent difference if you measure the
top six inches so it's it's really
interesting to see this we can calculate
the sequestration rates which is
basically the difference between them
over the amount of years that the
experiment was run and we can see that
that theom is the highest and makes
sense negative one and these texture
effects at least for temperate climates
are common that we see that the
increases in carbon stocks in notil are
least likely in these heav heavier clay
soils that's something that I found
couple time different times um in other
side by-side experiments with differing
textures so why does noil not lead to
consistent differences in carbon stocks
let's look at why we have this very
intense stratification of carbon at the
surface
but plow till has greater carbon in the
plow layer and below the plow layer that
makes up for those differences so when
we were just sampling to 30 cmers or
even 15 20 cmers you see that huge notel
sequestration story but here at the clay
LOM where there was absolutely no
differences big big big um difference at
the surface but was pretty much made up
at 6 to 12 Ines and then slightly more
deeper
down lomy sand it's similar except
there's probably more movement of carbon
through the profile because it's there's
more larger pore spaces but same story
no till huge difference at the surface
and then it makes it up at 12 to 18
inches we see which is similar to the
literature much greater um carbon
stratification in noil Grain experiments
the majority of the carbon inputs are
coming from corn Stover whereas the
majority of input puts um from a corn
silage system actually are coming from
the root so it makes sense that there's
less stratification in a corn silage
system we had some methodological
challenges
measuring carbon stocks at the Musgrave
Farm um so know what you're getting into
if you're thinking about doing some
carbon stock work at
Musgrave uh there's a lot of inorganic
carbon or or carbonates at depth in the
B Horizon and deeper in the soil um
makes sense we know these are high lime
soils why they're are productive Alphas
sols honey o are state soil but I was
really surprised that when you go down 9
to 12 inches 12 to 16 inches we had
about 40 to 70% of our total carbon
being inorganic carbon so that creates
challenges in terms of capturing what
the organic carbon story is which is
what we're really after
here so we had it cover crops drilled in
the experiment they led to some marginal
increases at the
surface but the remaining cover crop
effects had significant interactions
with the tillage system that means
something happened there was interaction
between the tillage and the cover crops
and this is unique I don't want to
um um it's an important finding I think
that should be tested with further
research but basically we found an
interesting signature that the plowing
down at cover crops actually reduced the
carbon in the plow layer
um and one hypothesis of why that could
be happening is positive priming kind of
where carbon inputs enable microbes to
jump start existing organic matter in
the
profile so some key takeaway messages
notil consistently has greater carbon
stocks at the surface but um this
doesn't necessarily translate to Greater
soil soil organic carbon across sites
cover crops lead to Marginal increases
at the surface and at one set we saw
this interaction which I think can be
tested in future long-term corn corn
grain
experiments and I also think we really
need to emphasis on carbon inputs as a
mechanism we've tend to emphasize this
tillage um mechanism but I think we've
um need need more emphasis on carbon
input side of the story and this
framework This research can really help
inform sampling and interpretation of
new carbon credit and and um emphasis in
New York we're going to be having a lot
of carbon stock data being generated in
the future due to this emphasis and we
need a way to be able to interpret it
and we need to maybe question why people
are going down so
deep so bringing it all together soil
health and carbon sequestration this
triple threat to agriculture requires
this emphasis on sustainable soil
management increasing carbon inputs
reducing disturbance always the same
story good good story soil Health
assessment and benchmarks can help us
inform management and policy predictive
models can help improve the cost
Effectiveness so we can have a very
comprehensive soil Health test but with
with um less
cost no till has consistent soil Health
climate resiliency and economic benefits
so it's really important to remember
that but it might not lead to this
carbon stock story um might not lead to
consistent differences in carbon
sequestration in temp climates I think
there's a lot of evidence that in drier
climates and more tropical climates
might have a bigger role need more
emphasis on carbon inputs and as
researchers we need to tell folks a
story don't assume that the carbon stock
or the soil Health trends that you see
at the top soil are going to hold true
when you go deeper into the soil so
we're going to need more um work that
goes deeper but probably not too deep
luckily we're not in the midwest where
you have to go down a meter so that's a
good good news
so I want to thank thank my committee
Harold for giving me space and Direction
over the last five and a half years to
become scientist I am johanes Layman
Matt Ryan support from the committee Bob
schindelbeck
who um is has been really important in
all of this work as a author on all of
these chapters um so consider him part
of my committee as well great New York
soil health Team great lab group Mike
Davis at the willsboro farm a lot of
undergraduate help and then everyone
from the Cornell soil Health lab really
appreciative of everyone so thank you
and I can take some
questions thank you was fantastic
congratulations to this great set of
works and well presented um I was
wondering I wanted to go back to this
dairy uh cropping systems and you you
saw you don't that that you uh had sort
of intermediate solid carbon levels
between um the uh serial grain cropping
systems and the veg cropping systems and
I was wondering you said something about
um that uh you would assume that that
the dairy farming systems have a more
complete removal of abovegr biomass as
fder um but yet it was still higher is
there an opportunity to ask questions
about what the quality of input
especially later on you said we need to
have more emphasis on quantity but is
this maybe an opportunity to ask
questions about the quality of input
which Dar manure input would be very
different from prop residue input yeah
it would be interesting to have an
experiment where I had a lot of manure
but that obviously can change then that
the Cornell Dairy Farm you see
incredibly High stocks from manure but
carbon inputs I think is is a big part
of it but also the quality is huge in
our in some of the Penn State work that
I've been a part of finding that the
although significantly lower biomass for
crimson clover for example um than than
a grass cover crop seeing influences on
how that's driving soil carbon fractions
so that it could I think it'd be the
same story whether it's crimson clover
or manure could have same similar and
triggering different carbon use
efficiencies is where each is getting
into um that that we we get more carbon
acral due to switching on different
microw wheel Pathways that know uh
result in different carbon use
efficiencies that are maybe with
material that have lower CN ratios is a
higher carbon use yeah definitely I
think it's important great thank you
yeah y youi oh wonderful talk thank you
and it's really I mean you expert on the
soil compy state of New York and that so
also same issue about the cropping
system and then you showed that in the
uh or or have very low soil on the
what's the what's the reasons um I'll
Debbie is actually going to do a whole
presentation on Orchard soil Health in a
couple weeks so that will be answered
but basically there's there's a huge
degree there's some very healthy
Orchards and then degraded but Orchard
conventional Orchard management is to
leave basically bare bare strip so no
carbon
inputs little life to create this
non-competitive Zone for the trees so
that's potentially one important
reason can I ask yeah yeah
sure so you you show the tillage the
nonage comparing and your
kage basically increase the carbon in
deeper layers in especially Clay is that
due to the uh root change Roo zone or
rooting Ro rooting depths or the because
for the vertical carbon
movement down to the below the
fling yeah now I think there's a lot of
factors the most simple factor is you're
just you're just incorporating it deeper
in the soil profile um so those inputs
are getting getting spread out
um but yeah and I mean there's a lot of
potential interactions with soil
structure and compaction that could be
driving things as
well thanks
presentation I
was we are
toing more
Caron and this
be I was wondering
if this hold true also if you're just
looking at the productivity of the soil
all the other advantages
um yeah yeah no I think there's there's
tremendous reason to do noil but maybe
it's not going to lead to by itself not
going to lead to the carbon
sequestration part but huge benefits for
surface resiliency increasing
infiltration and and and reducing
production costs a lot of farmers think
about the savings with no till help them
spend extra 20 25 bucks an acre to do
cover crops um so there's so many
reasons to do noil but I think we really
need to emphasize this carbon input part
I think one thing one of the reasons
that we might have seen a difference at
the no till the grain experiment um is
potentially no till mediated higher
yields of the corn crop leading to the
carbon stock differences so that would
actually be my best hypothesis for that
one so I think we need to think about
the input the inputs telling a bigger
part of the story sorry
r
so question is the value of function you
devel I wonder why you
useum for predict that but not is there
any idea about no I'm did it kind of
well I did it based on the individual
influence of each predictor variable
whether it's producing the rmsse you're
helping to increase um the the fit um
but yeah no so that one was it was based
on what I had access to what made sense
for maybe capturing soil soil type
effects as well um yeah no so was you
maybe you had f space app choosing
the I just I ran a lot of different
models and kind of did add a step by
step addition and subtraction of
different predictor variables to see
what the not not sure how the be this
idea have be related with that magnesium
bonds to pigments and pigment bonds
proteins interesting oh
yeah I didn't think of that we need this
little chemist to help
me yeah sorry
sorry is very similar what I'm doing
right now so the of
lay and how about deep layer decrease or
or very s yeah this is just one
experiment so I don't want everyone to
jump on that result but I think it it is
a possible mechanism it was interesting
to see that there was that interaction
where it didn't happen in the noil
system but it happened in the plow tail
system
um but yeah I don't have um
Dana the
uh research that he did is
remarkable and raises many many
interesting
questions my primary question
is with the model that been using and
predictions that you could
potentially sequester roughly
3.8% I think of what we need to
question did that surprise anyone is
that high or low is that reason for Joy
or is that is that good or bad no I mean
I think that's just what what it what an
estimate is for what agriculture's
capacity is um I I think we need to also
focus on all the other important uh
climate mitigation strategies and energy
was there hope or higher higher
no I don't think necess necessarily I
think there's a lot one thing that's
challenging in the public there's a lot
of kind of overhype that we could be
promising that this is going to solve
the problem when it maybe it's going to
play a smaller role than we
think so let's
give this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu
you